Hey YouTubers! it's Charlie. Thank you everyone that asked questions
on the Batman vs. Superman trailer, The Flash and Arrow episodes this week.
There's a lot of stuff to talk about, so I tried to compress this just so I could do as much as possible.
So I'll just start with the Batman vs Superman trailer. I know it's technically Batman v Superman
I'm not a huge fan of the fact that they went with the "v" instead of the outright "versus"
but I think once we get closer to the actual movie, they'll explain the logic behind that.
I think it'll be part of the story of the film, because they will be coming together in Justice League.
For the most part, this will be Batman and Superman at each others' throats.
Speaking of which, the first big question, the Alfred voice-over, where he talks about
fear and feeling of powerlessness turning good men cruel.
He's actually talking about all of the main characters, not just Lex Luthor and Superman.
He's talking about Batman and even the regular people like the senators.
Thematically it's like the John F. Kennedy speech, the famous speech, "The Only Thing We Have to Fear is Fear Itself".
As you would guess, all of the heroes will be able to 'overcome their fear'
by the end of the film. Lex Luthor will not. That's why he's the villain.
He will succumb to becoming a cruel person. Even though Batman looks like
he's really ready to make Superman bleed in this.
So next big question, how does Batman beat Superman in this film if Superman is a god.
or the closest you can get to being a god.
We know that in this universe Superman does kill, which is actually a departure from previous films.
Him killing Zod was a really big deal. This scene actually here takes place where that happened.
That's Batman really tiny on screen. You can barely see him.
The way Zack Snyder explained the logic of killing Zod, is that Superman felt like he had no other choice.
He obviously has a choice whether or not to kill Batman.
So he's not going to kill Batman. Batman however does not make that distinction.
He's totally willing to kill Superman.
Add to that, he has unlimited money, and he's every bit as cunning as genius Lex Luthor.
He'll find a weak in Superman to exploit. Just like Lex Luthor will.
It might not be the same weakness, but he will find something.
There are things that Superman can't fight, like internet piracy. How does Superman
fight internet piracy? How does Superman stop a trailer from being leaked? Solve that problem.
He can't heat vision everyone's computer in the world.
Next big question, Batplane looks like it's shooting bullets at people.
A lot of people are thinking that this is the Batplane and Batman is trying to kill these people here.
I don't think that's the case. That's not confirmed Batwing and we don't know that Batman is flying it.
It could be someone else co-opting Batman's technology, or it could be some other criminal element in the film.
Lex Luthor is probably not gonna be the only villain we see.
Speaking of villains, that big voice- over "do you bleed?"
A lot of people are wondering if that's maybe another person in the film
like another villain character and not Batman.
I still think that it's Batman affecting his voice with technology.
I noticed a few people commenting that Kevin Smith said something
about them affecting Batman's voice with technology
as opposed to him doing it himself;
Like doing the Christian Bale "Batman voice" technique.
I can't confirm that but
I do think that is Batman saying that line.
There's no way that they would tease us
with a Batman vs. Superman punch-out
without actually doing it on screen.
That would be the biggest middle finger to everyone watching this trailer.
Yes they will settle their differences by the end of the trailer
but not before they punch it out just like a little bit.
That doesn't even address what Wonder Woman's role is going to be in this film.
If she's every bit as strong as SuperMan what is she going to be doing?
Most of the time in her comics her MO is that she is a diplomat so
I think she'd going to be something of an intermediary.
Like I said before though, most of this film is going to be Batman and Superman.
I think Wonder Woman will be in there but
she won't have as big a role as those two characters.
Next big question: Neil deGrasse Tyson. I saw a lot of people wondering
if he's going to be tied to the Cyborg character because
Cyborg had a scientist dad that worked at the S.T.A.R. Labs.
I don't think that's the case. I think that Neil deGrasse Tyson
in the movie will be playing Neil deGrasse Tyson.
Because a lot of Sc-Fi & Superhero films want to tie themselves
to the real world and seem more realistic
they'll invoke real life characters in the films.
It would be like Stan Lee playing Stan Lee in a Marvel film.
Neil deGrasse Tyson is just like the "rock star"
of the science world so
he's one of the more fun people to bring into a film
just because he's really good on camera.
If you've never watched his show Cosmos, it's a lot of fun and you should check it out.
Next big thing: the IMAX screening.
So what's happening is because of the leak
Zach Snyder added a couple shots to the IMAX screening.
So if you're going to a theater to see the trailer on Monday
You'll see more footage than we saw in this official trailer here.
I don't think we'll see Lex Luthor, Wonder Woman, Aquaman or those characters.
I think the extra scenes they added will just add some more context for what's going on in the film.
If you remember Avengers: Age of Ultron they waited until the third trailer
to put Vision in.
So moving into Flash territory. I know a lot of you guys are asking about
the staggered episodes because
next week is episode nineteen of the Flash but it's episode twenty of Arrow.
So here's what's going on.
The timeline of both shows is meant to sync up so
when episode nineteen of The Flash is happening
episode nineteen of Arrow is happening.
it's a little messed up that the episodes are out of sync but
the way they wrote the episodes
they totally work. It's not gonna completely mess up the story of each episode.
They designed it that way on purpose.
Like when they do cross-over episodes they try to make it so that it works on it's own.
Even if you miss
that week's episode of the other show so
if you see episode twenty of Arrow but
you miss episode twenty of The Flash
it's not going to completely mess stuff up.
I think one of the best moments that you guys commented on
on Arrow this week was that Oliver said "why don't
we just get Barry to solve this problem".
That's been the question ever since this season started.
Like how come Oliver just doesn't call The Flash to come and fix his problem
especially the mid-season finale.
Felicity's answer to that is that Barry
is just like so effed up in the head that he
can barely handle getting up in the morning.
So regardless of what you think of Felicity's excuse they did address it.
I think they'll continue to do that. They'll say "hey why don't we just call this person"
and some other character will say "well we can't because x,y,z".
You also have to consider that Oliver is getting ready to
or it seems like he's getting ready to join the League of Assassins.
I don't think that we won't address that on The Flash.
Someone will say something about that.
Next big question:
WTF is going on with Eddie and Iris
and is that going to inform Eddie turning bad or doing something crazy.
We have a little more context for Eddie
killing these two cops in the trailer.
No I don't think that has anything to do with Grodd. I think that's
the shape shifter.
This character is Everyman from the comics. That's who this is.
So when ever we see Barry Allen fighting himself in the trailer
that's also from that episode probably. It's just the  shape shifter taking on
properties of other people that he touches.
The fun part is that the Everyman project is something that Lex Luthor did
in the DC universe.
It's a subitle tie to Lex but I don't think they'll ever be able to mention LexCorp on The Flash.
The next couple of episodes will give you a better idea of
of how Eddie's relationship with team Flash is going to change
going into the season finale.
He is a good character but
I think that events will conspire to
make him do something that he's not proud of.
Eobard Thawne, The Reverse Flash,
will still be the big villain this season
like they're not going to change that. There won't be any dramatic left turns.
It's all building up to this big team up moment.
Firestorm, Ra's Amell, and The Flash vs. The Reverse Flash.
What I do think is going to happen is that The Reverse Flash will start targeting Iris
and then that will put Eddie and Barry in this really weird situation.
Moving into Arrow territory. I know everybody is asking about the League of Assassins, Oliver joining up,
maybe becoming the next Ra's al Ghul
and Thea getting in the Lazarus Pit.
Just to start with the first thing: Oliver joining the League of Assassins.
I don't think he's going to immediately become Ra's al Ghul.
He'll just join the League so that Thea can use the Lazarus Pit.
I think the next couple of episodes after that, before the finale,
will deal with the idea of succession.
And no I don't think that Nyssa is just going to sit idly by. I think that she will try to help team Arrow in some way.
Next big question: who is that mystery woman that we keep seeing in all the trailers?
The woman who looks like she is related to Nyssa or Ra's al Ghul.
She could be Nyssa's mother.
What I don't think is that she is a comic book character that we haven't heard about yet.
Like Lady Shiva.
Typically characters like that, that are really big
they announce those when they cast them.
So I do think that she is a character that flows from the comic books
but I don't think that she's like a comic book super hero or super villain.
Next big question: what's going on with the spin off?
I know a lot of you are asking so what's happened is
that's they've finished filming both seasons of Arrow and The Flash
and there was a scene with pictures of spin off characters on a roof top.
We don't know if the scene is going to be part of either episodes of the finale.
What I think is going to happen is
it's going to be like that Fight Club trailer where it's not
part of an episode it's just like a fun promo moment.
I think what will happen is that they'll air the finales of both shows
and then they'll air a teaser for the spin off show
because they haven't even finished filming the spin off yet.
They haven't even finished casting it yet.
They have filmed footage with those characters, with some of the spin off characters.
So what they're doing is they're probably just teeing up what's going to be happening in the spin off.
It's totally possible if they are filming a trailer for that
they could wait till Comic Con to air it but
I think that they would want to air that after the finale of The Flash and Arrow just to maximize viewership.
Right now all the spin off stuff is still just a lot of speculation.
We still don't know how Katie Lutz is coming back.
We still don't know who some of those mystery characters are,
and we still don't know who the villain is.
Thank you everyone for submitting questions. These are always a ton of fun to do.
So next week new episodes of Arrow and the Flash.
If there's any really crazy new footage in the IMAX Batman vs. Superman trailer
I'll let you guys know. I'll do a new video for it.
I'm also going to be seeing Avengers: Age of Ultron on Tuesday night
so I'm going to do a non-spoilery review of that.
So be sure to subscribe to get that. That's going to be a lot of fun.
I'm still trying to get through the rest of my Daredevil videos.
I've seen the whole season I just haven't had time to make videos for all the episodes yet.
Tomorrow will be new Game of Thrones so I'll be doing a bonus video/episode video for that just like normal. With a new round of the giveaway.
It's been a really awesome week. Lots of Star Wars stuff happening, lots of Marvel, lots of DC stuff.
So while you guys wait for me to finish all those other videos you can
click here to watch the Batman v. Superman trailer like 10 or 15 more times
and you can click here to watch the Star Wars trailer again.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody lets high five. I'll see you guys tonight.